a una reunión inédita el presidente
estadounidense joe biden diálogo con los
ministros de exteriores y de defensa de
ucrania consolidando el primer encuentro
cara a cara con altos funcionarios de
dicho país desde que comenzó la guerra
con dos principales conclusiones mayor
cooperación y más sanciones
que ningún otro país brindó más apoyo a
ucrania que eeuu y esto es crucial la
resistencia ucraniana y las armas
occidentales en su mayoría son
estadounidenses son la receta para el
éxito en el campo de batalla vemos mucha
voluntad y vemos que eeuu está dispuesta
a seguir adelante con más sanciones
de sanciones
la serie de compromisos de bailén en
polonia continuó con un encuentro con el
presidente polaco andrzej duda
el mandatario estadounidense reconoció
el papel de dicho país en la acogida de
refugiados a donde han llegado más de la
mitad de los ucranianos que han huido de
la guerra así mismo reiteró su
compromiso con la defensa del territorio
por la cuestión a este hecho
coles
eeuu y mis colegas de este lado de la
mesa han escuchado decirlo muchas veces
tomamos el artículo 5 como un compromiso
sagrado no como algo descartable un
compromiso sagrado que se relaciona con
todos los miembros de la otan
un campamento de refugiados fue su
última parada
donde bardem se encontró con el alcalde
de varsovia y un grupo de ucranianos que
dejó su país por la guerra y está
lidiando cada día con vladimir putin
mire lo que le ha hecho a todo esta
gente que le hace pensar que no es un
carnicero el jueves washington aseguró
que acogería 100.000 refugiados
ucranianos y prometió mil millones de
dólares en ayuda humanitaria